answer mine it's actually not my job to
answer your questions are you prepared
to call h a terror group is it possible
to have a rational I've asked you two
questions should a mass stay in power
and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV the only place
where you get the truth you've done a
book on poetry poetry and music for the
many I love poetry we can agree on
that
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on Pi Morgan
uncensored knives are out for richy
sunak as the Prime Minister faces down
another conservative party Civil War is
it time for a general election will
debate plus are men secretly sick and
tired of women commentating on men's
football matches sporting bad boy Joey
Barton thinks so has said so and he'll
be here live to defend
himself live from London this is Pi's
Morgan
uncensored good evening from London
welcome to peers Morgan uncensored live
again from my home because I've still
got covid Rishi sunak became prime
minister with a crystal clear brief to
bring down the curtain on Britain's
political circus Boris Johnson had
brought disorder and deceit to to
Downing Street this trust brought
ridicule and ruin to the whole country
and all the while the conservative party
had indulged itself in an orgy of
mudslinging a Relentless shambolic
slugfest between the hardliners the
remainers the reformers the blue War the
European research group The Net Zero
group The Common Sense group the Boris
backers the truss anomic tossers but
they all forgot something fundamental
nobody cares richy sunak seemed to get
that he was the grown-up back in charger
for most of the first year of his tenure
in number 10 whether you think he's
doing a good job or not or like him or
not at least there was a truce in theor
Civil War and he bought embracing
competence and civility to the office
well that truce is well and truly over
last night his immigration Minister
Robert genrich dramatically quick
claiming version 8.0 of the useless
Rwanda policy is doomed to fail which
I've said it would be from day one today
the PM found herself giving an emergency
press conference to defend
that useless policy and his future I
will not allow a foreign Court to block
these flights if the Strasburg Court
chooses to intervene against the express
wishes of our Sovereign Parliament I
will do what is necessary to get flights
off and today's new laws already make
clear that the decision on whether to
comply with interim measures issued by
the European court is a decision for
British government ministers and British
government ministers alone
because it is your government not
criminal gangs or indeed foreign courts
who decides who comes here and who stays
in our country now of course our Rwanda
policy is just one part of our wider
strategy to stop the boats and that
strategy is
working well suddenly this has become a
very serious problem for Mr sunak if he
doesn't work his job may be on the line
rumors are already swirling about a wave
of resignations and a possible no
confidence vote next week and the
movement against him is clearly being
led by Suella braan who he fired as Home
Secretary for undermining him she was
out early this morning to do what she
does best pour some poison and fuel onto
the Flames you've condemned the leader
of your party's uncertain weak and
lacking in leadership you've said he
never had any intention of keeping his
promises you've accused him of betrayal
and Wishful Thinking isn't the truth
you're a headline Grabber who does it by
spreading poison even within your own
party and sometimes s honesty is
uncomfortable and if that upsets polite
Society then I'm sorry about that the
point is that we need to be honest we
need to be cleare eyed about the
situation right now we can't keep
failing the British people we have made
promises after promise we have put
forward plan after plan they have all
failed well she might be right about
this plan not working I never thought it
would work where she's wrong is thinking
she has a cat and hell's chance of being
a suitable replacement as Prime Minister
and for the Tories to be speculating
about knifing sunac and installing their
fourth leader in 18 months is complete
Insanity this country faces severe
challenges an ongoing cost of living
crisis a housing crisis an immigration
crisis an NHS crisis a public transport
crisis the list is endless people need
their leaders to get on with fix in the
country not bickering over which faction
of a conservative party they're in if
they can't do that then frankly they
deserve the Oblivion currently awaiting
them at the next election what join me
now to talk about this is talk TV's
International editor Isabelle oak shop
the talk TV contributor Paul lone Adrian
plus writer and commentator annah Farin
well welcome to all of you all right
Isabelle let's get into this off the top
Rishi sunak is facing as were his three
predecessors potential death at the
hands of probably the most disloyal
bunch of rat bags I've ever seen in
political history discuss well Piers I'm
happy to say that tonight I agree with
almost everything you said there Rishi
sunak government is teetering on the
brink here this is a genuine crisis for
the Prime Minister it's not that Robert
genrich is a particularly important or
pivotal or high-profile figure the man
who resigned uh last night is hardly a
household name it is the fact that
there's been a complete breakdown
already of discipline within his
administration and in theory we could
have a whole other year of this utter
sherad of rishy sunak popping up to
deliver emergency legislation and
emergency press conferences to try to
regain the initiative and I just don't
see how we can stagger on how can the
country be expected to stagger on with
this fast for another 12 months I just
don't think it's
sustainable Paula I mean what concerns
me about this is there are far more
important things for these people to be
doing than bickering and squabbling
amongst themselves but it seems like
they've got an addiction to this
completely and here in lies ry's problem
I also agree with pretty much everything
that you've just said in your monologue
and that's his problem that across the
board from left to right there is an
agreement that that Rishi sunak is
letting this country down that he's
watching this country crumble and doing
nothing about it other than providing a
facade we're not interested in the
European convention on human rights
we're not interested in in in in the
boats and and people seeking Asylum what
we're interested in is the fact that
this country is failing and it's failing
at every single level
peers I mean and I it's interesting
isn't it what Paula said there because
if you actually judge him fairly rishy
sunak he's got the illegal numbers on
boats down by I think 30% which is not a
bad thing to have achieved
this year his inflation is pretty much
where he hoped it would be when I sat
down with him at the start of the year
so on some of his metrics he's ticking a
few boxes here but getting no credit
because his party is so split now that
no one's really focusing on any wins all
they want is to tear each other apart
you have to remember Piers that I think
in many ways Rishi sunak set himself up
for this one of his main pledges was
stopping the boats not just getting it
down by some percentage points but
stopping it and therefore people are
holding him to that metric which on that
metric he has failed and if we go back
actually he didn't have the majority
vote of the conservative party or its
members he wasn't elected in a stoning
majority like what happened with Bor
Johnson um in 2019 even though I have
very strong disagreements with Boris in
some areas so Rishi sunak was already on
a quite difficult ground and he had to
really prove to people that he could uh
commit and deliver the things that he
promised and also unite the party and he
hasn't been able to do that and
therefore the swords are coming out and
therefore I think that actually in many
ways um he should have expected this
when he couldn't fulfill the very thing
that he said he would
do I mean I think uh Isabel actually one
of his big problems was making swell
braan Home Secretary again in the first
place she'd already been fired from that
job once and I said at the time on this
show this is complete Madness to bring
her straight back she's obviously
damaged goods and I thought then not
trust trustworthy given the way she had
lied before uh but look you make your
bed and you have to lie on it and he's
now in big trouble no question somebody
else who was in big trouble before he
got turfed out was our friend Boris
Johnson who he put up the most
extraordinary defense of yesterday for
day one of his testimony in the co
inquiry uh let's play a clip this is the
first clip I want to play you from
today's uh uh evidence that he gave this
is where he talks about party
gate the vers of events that has entered
the popular Consciousness about what is
supposed to have happened in Downing
Street is a million miles from the
reality of what actually happened in
number 10 not just the media coverage
but the the the dramatic representations
that we're now having of this are
absolutely
absurd so I'm just puty much at L piece
in one of the little problems of being
at home you have to do it all yourself
uh with my my competent handlers
obviously um
also is my makeup all right because I've
had a lot of commentary that last night
I went full George Hamilton I fourth so
I did wonder if you were competing with
me yesterday
PE not possible to compete with you cor
I have no concerns about my skin color
just for the record uh better make sure
you got your passport P you're off to
Rwanda only you could say that Isabelle
Boris exactly and that's the point um
Isabelle let me let me talk about Boris
Johnson's initial uh lie again there and
I'm going to call them lies because
they're lies the truth is uh over 80
people at Downing Street including him
got fined by the police for breaking
their own Co rules why are we talking
about this this is ridiculous you know
Boris Johnson is Boris Johnson is the
single most important witness in this
sherard of a covid inquiry and yet he's
only got two days of testimony in which
there are multiple breaks and long lunch
hours and they all pack up and go home
at half past 4 and we've devoted any
time of that to talking about party gate
I find that absolutely absurd
look okay I'm not defending him on this
I'm not defending him on this you'll be
glad to hear you are so Isabelle you are
so completely wrong about party gate and
why it doesn't matter I didn't say party
gate matter because it went right to the
no hang on let me finish it went right
to the heart of public trust in the
government if they weren't obeying their
own rules why said most of the public
should they be obeying them it broke
trust between a government and it people
in a health emergency I agree I
completely agree I don't think there was
any why shouldn't he be asked about it
because it's the co inquiry and we've
parked that issue we know he was wrong
he lost the room on that yonks ago there
is no point in devoting Precious time to
it I'm not defending him I think he's
lying about it Isabelle you don't seem
to mind you don't seem to mind that he
comes into this inquiry and tells lie
after lie after lie keeps having CAU up
on it let me well let me play the next
one look he denied ever saying let the
virus rip let's see what happened when
he tried denying it in the inquiry the
notion that you as a government would
let the virus rip was your own phrase
was it not what I'm what I'm saying is
that this was a phrase in common uh
parland at the time s Patrick Val's di
is
27391 Page 92 actually having a
discussion a meeting with the PM about
quote letting it rip the Prime Minister
meeting begins to argue for letting it
rip saying yes there will be more
casualties but so be it they've had a
good Innings we should let it rip a
bit I don't know what
you time after time I don't think that
that is at the heart of the matter is
not this emotive language about letting
it rip because obviously that is blunt
and it is uh not something that most
people would agree with in terms of the
way that was framed what he was talking
about there was a perfectly sensible
scientific approach which all the
experts around him were recommending up
until mid-march this is a so-called her
immunity approach and all those top
people were advising it not just Boris
Johnson at that time and look if your
agenda is to present him as someone who
was a totally callous granny killer then
I think you are way off the Mark I don't
know whether you actually listened to
him did you actually listen to him what
I Isabelle I damn I damn people by their
own words right take a look at Miss clip
this is the third one this is him when
he gets all tearful again one of his
preferred tricks in this inquiry when he
talks about being an ICU himself
when when I went into itu to in
intensive care I I saw around me a um a
lot of people who were who were not
actually
elderly um and in fact they were
middle-aged
men um and they were they were quite
like
me and some of us were going to make it
and some of us weren't I knew from that
experience what an falling disease this
is you see Paula he wants us to all to
feel sorry for him he's welling up again
he's like I'm the human being I really
felt for this but the rhetoric that
they're repeating to time and again
shows shows a callous use of language
Let It Rip let the oldies die bed
blockers blah blah blah it's totally
different to miss act and sherard
putting on on this inquiry and we know
it's totally different because I want to
remind everybody about party gate and
the algra Straton and the alra Stratton
video that was leaked uh where we could
see how funny she thought it was that
she was being asked to define whether a
party had taken place I don't know if
you remember that that video appears um
and that is the disdain that we were
treated with so when Isabelle denounces
the fact that we are looking at party
gate there are two reasons why we're
looking at party party gate number one
because to this day there are people
quite proudly saying that covid was a
con there are people still today
suggesting that Co was not real and that
some and that somehow it wasn't to be
taken seriously and the reason why I'm
seeing it all day long on Twitter all
all day long
onter hang on hang on I'm just saying
there are literally thousands of people
all day long who think CO's con and one
of the reasons they often cite is if it
was that serious why were Boris Johnson
and all the people at number 10
noty can I just make my can I just make
my second point my second point about
why party gate is so important is
because when a government is identified
as lying to its people during a time of
an crisis of an emergency what on Earth
is going to happen the next time we are
confronted are you going to trust the
government exactly and that is why I
concerned I want I want to bring an in
here an this goes to the reason I think
Isabelle so off base on this at the
heart of this questioning with Boris
Johnson is a question of trust and even
now he keeps being caught out lying he
cannot stop lying and that was what
brought him down as prime minister and
that was what caused lot of the problems
in the pandemic that was the key problem
at the heart of his own leadership look
I I think I I don't agree with you on
this pier I think Boris Johnson has many
shortcomings and I'm one of the first
people uh to name them but when it came
to the lockdown I think many of us are
actually forgetting that we were we were
locked down for for years this wasn't
just uh Boris Johnson completely callous
you know let let the uh lockdown end and
let everybody do whatever they wanted
that was the exact opposite that was
happening and actually there is still
not uniformity when it comes to
scientists and experts about whether
lockdown was even effective we still are
figuring out no no but but the idea the
idea that Boris Johnson asking questions
about whether or not we should open up
asking whether or not this is the right
approach taking a slightly different
view is somehow something to be
demonized you're missing my point both
you and Isabelle both you and Isabelle
are missing my point he keeps saying he
didn't say things which they then
literally proved him immediately he did
I I don't know what it's like to have a
novel virus in a pressure tooker
conditions where the entire world is
locking down and making decisions that
are fundamental pres people people might
say things and private conversations in
an informal way that taken out of
context looks horrifying I don't think
that gets the of question he's the prime
minister of the country
wellist Prim Minister inconsistent
science means consistent leadership and
we did not have consistent you know what
does terrible is it too much to expect
the prime minister to tell the truth is
that too much is it too much to expect
you to give reasonable Credence to the
fact that a man who nearly died of covid
showed genuine emotion when he was
talking about it is that too much to ask
because by your negative interpretations
of everything you as much to undermine
trust in politics as anybody else I'll
tell you why it's too much to ask me
I'll tell you why it's too much to ask
me because I know too many people who
lost their loved ones through the
incompetence of him and his his
government and the callousness of his
rhetoric that's come out in this inquiry
makes me puke so yeah I'm afraid I'm not
going to shed a tear for Boris Johnson's
crocodile tears I'm just not when ites
sta actually his decision making led to
thousands of people dying who shouldn't
have died I will weep for them as I have
done for the ones I know not for him
anyway let's change the subject let's
change the subject to uh this happened
today which is a BBC newsreader having a
moment uh this is am mashiri a chief
presenter for the BBC News
[Music]
Channel live from London this is BBC
News I don't know why we did the
sensored version of that we're
uncensored for God's sake where's the
uncensored version Don't out careful I
was just well ex I did think we should
end on that because I could tell both
you and I probably wanted to give me the
bird and if we do by the way we're
uncensored you Fire Away Ladies we're
too classy For That We're Not Gonna Do
We're not gonna do that we were going to
talk about Prince Harry but I've run out
of time and I've got no interest other
than to point out
to Prince Harry in his in his high court
case uh demanding Royal protection of
course he does because he wants to have
his Royal cake and eat it he apparently
said today that he felt forced to leave
the Royals and it wasn't a choice what
he'd forgotten is what he said in his
statement when they left in January 2020
when he said after many months of
reflection we have chosen chosen to make
a transition this year in starting to
car A new role he can't even remember
his own pup eyes anyway pack Lov it to
see you all thank you very much indeed
uncensored next football bad boy Joey
Barton Sparks a sexism Scandal by
claiming women shouldn't be talking
about men's football on television he
joins me live next and I suspect knowing
Joey bar he won't be backing
down
[Music]
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well criminals to
using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
to today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any your will because
he delivered the ref rendum that he said
he would deliver the tor's love a scrap
you can almost see this coming around
the tracks with sella bravman she's
heading up one side and rishy soon at
the other the police are pro Palestine
that is just not right you swearing Al
in the police to act without fear or
favor the co inquiry seems to have
turned into a sort of pantomim there's
not really any substance to it it's hard
to know whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by as Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £40
million so far so40 million pounds so
far result nil absolutely nil are we
only going to be trusting sources like
meta and Google where is our unbiased
news going to come from Kell in winter
is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin B
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat
for a if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan you have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man mous he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got a house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to Res yes cuz I cannot continue
my work when I say I am right I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call Hass a terror group
is it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should aass stay
in power and are they terror group
you're refusing to answer either of them
that is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that
[Music]
as a player Joey Barton is one of the
most controversial men in football
outspoken aggressive tempestuous rarely
out of the headlines as a manager it
wasn't much different this week Barton
has stirred up a sexism Scandal by
launching a furious broadside against
female pundits analyzing men's football
on television it all began with a post
saying women shouldn't be talking with
any kind of authority in the men's game
come on let's be serious it's a totally
different game I cannot take a thing
they say seriously in the men's Arena
well since then he's been called a
sexist misogynist dinosaur but is he
saying out loud what some men maybe many
men are thinking as well well Joey Bon
joins me live now Joey great to see you
thank you very much for joining
me P nice to see you you okay looking
well you've had an interesting day uh
take me back to the initial post that
you put up on Twitter clearly
inflammatory but that's your way did you
expect the reaction that you were going
to
get no well it's it's it's part of the
the the um you know when you say what
you what sometimes you're thinking it
can it can obviously lead to you know a
reaction it wasn't entitled you know I
didn't do that I seen or certainly I've
seen in my game where you know I do feel
P I have enough credibility to say I'm
probably a bonafied um expert um this
kind of tokenism creeping in especially
when it comes to you know it's ruining
certainly it's ruining my experience of
of both the game and obviously the the
journalistic standards you know it it's
um It's not nothing to do with sex
sexism at
all I mean what is your particular
complaint is it that women have not
played the game to the highest level and
therefore they're not qualified to talk
about
it P look I'm against tokenism and I'm
against um you know poor journalistic
standards especially when it comes to
the game I love which is football you
know I know to everyone's game you know
but there's two two slightly different
uh variants obviously the men's game and
and the women's game and all of a sudden
if you speak out in in favor of uh you
know saying a men's game people come to
here and you know I'm getting accused of
being rightwing because of I've said
what clearly a lot of people are
thinking about the journalistic
standards of some of the you know female
commentary and ccoms and punditry that
that I'm seeing um in the game that I
feel as I say I think I'm a Bonafide
expert
in I mean you said today uh I stand by
everything I've said on women commenting
and cooms on the men's football like me
talking about knitting or net ball way
out of my comfort zone uh we've gone too
far you can't watch a game now without
hearing the nonsense any man who says
otherwise is an absolute fart parcel I
mean do you accept that some of your
language here was a little
incend well well that is X or Twitter as
it was once known that that is what what
those platforms are kind of used for as
as we all use them it's just a tool um
and it it leads this debate or you know
I don't want to see sexism in football
but if we don't talk about this properly
and debate this properly this is just
going to further rise and and rise and
ruin um as I say the experience of of
watching you know Elite level men's
football and and as I say every
everywhere you turn now um there's
there's for for what I would deem as an
unqualified opinion um commentating
pontificating about the sport I love and
it's it's ruining my experience of it um
and it's it's it's to fuel this woke
agenda and if we're not careful we're
going to in increase sexism massively
because it's it's got to be a true
meritocracy pce we have to have people
who are uh Jo let me let me ask you
again you haven't actually answer that
to do those
roles right but the question that I
asked you which you haven't answered yet
what is it about the women that you
think is is inappropriate is it because
they have not not played the game at the
highest level of men's
football no Pete p as you know with me
I'll never not answer a question um no
it's absolutely not that it's about as I
say you have to be there on Merit like
you can't you can't be there to to fit
this woke agenda that we've currently
got going on in society um you know
there you don't have to have played the
game you know lots of managers haven't
played the game at a at a high level
lots of good commentary people haven't
played the game a high high level kind
of Mark Chapman Rory Smiths of this
world um but they've earned the right
via you know hard work and over a
prolonged period to get into that space
obviously it helps talk about the men's
game if you've played that men's game
the higher the level arguably the better
because it gives you a unique experience
there's a lot of similarities between
both Sports peers absolutely no danger
in that but the men's game has just
played at a completely different speed
with a completely different skill set
needed you know and for someone to stand
there and say I would have done this in
this situation or he's made a mistake
there who have no experience of that um
and and it's not just one or two it's
it's been taken over um you know and it
ruins the experience for for most men
and it's the men's game and I feel I
don't I don't want to come across a
sexist absolutely not I've got a
wonderful daughter wonderful wife my
grandmother big matriarch I want women
at Men's games you know at Bristol
Rovers we had here game two and it a
great initiative to get women in the
stadiums but if we're going to talk
about the technical nuances of of elite
level football and we want to educate
the audience which is the punditry co-
commentary role then we we must do that
with the most credible people not people
who tick boxers or fill quoters and I do
feel that at this moment in time okay
but let me let me put two names to you
you know in let me put two names to you
or three names right you've got someone
like Alex Scott who won a World Cup as a
women's player right which is eluded
eluded our men's team
I'm sorry I'm being told she didn't win
the World Cup but she certainly competed
at a very high level for England for a
very long time you've got Laura Woods
who's one of the best I think one of the
best football presenters in the game
she's a woman she's been Furious today
about what you said um you know what why
should people like that be excluded from
the men's
game no I'm absolutely not saying that
I'm saying if you've V the right to be
there with with credibility and and and
Hardware over a long period you should
Absol absolutely be there I've got a
daughter I wondered if she would would
like to Peter to to have the opportunity
to commentate or co- commentate on a
men's game if that what you the men's
football game if that's what she chooses
but she should be there because she's
worked incredibly hard over a long
period has got a great skill set not be
just because she's a woman and to fill a
quoter and this woke agenda this
tokenism we we have to be very very
careful look at look at what it's doing
to other sports and um you know I don't
want to see the sport that I love um
ruined and and my experience as as a man
it's ruining I can't watch it tell you
now for and and and a lot of the
information is technically incorrect
that that these so-called experts women
experts are saying about the men's game
they're factually incorrect but but
someone but but Joe someone like Alex
Scott right who has had tremendous
success as a player been very successful
as a television presenter is she not
qualified does she not meet your
criteria to talk about the men's game to
talk about the men's game
yeah yeah well she she hasn't played in
she hasn't played in in any any games
I've played in and been evolved as a
manager in
657 professional men's games now the
women's games a fantastic game at the
minute thriven I've never seen as many
opportunities you know the England team
wins stuff at at that in in the women's
game I think sander vman's done a great
job raising the awareness for the
women's game it's phenomenal but the
men's game and the women's game in this
country are different one's about 200
years old and one's about 30 40 years
old if you go back to kind of donc cast
the bells and and the inception for
women I've lived through it I've played
football with women of no but Joe here's
my here's my problem with the argument
right if you look at people like John
mson greatest commentator I've ever seen
Barry Davis right up there Clive tilsley
Dez Liam right none of them ever play
professional football by your criteria
why are they more qualified than someone
like Alex Scott who has at least played
for her country many times why are they
more qualified having not played
professional football in the end the
rules of football are the same whether
you're male or foot or female they're
exactly the same
rules the same rules but it's a complete
football's about a lot more than rules
PE it's time and space and velocity and
impact and challenges and and and the
games are at two different speeds it's
almost like if if I decide Sunday I'm
going
um have go to Formula One and I start
saying listen I would have done this if
I was LE Hamilton in this corner and i'
have done that and and rightly card or
or Damon Hill or you know Eddie Jordan
Jordan or whatever would rightly turn
around and say what you on about and I'd
say well I drive a car I've got a
driving license yeah but one's going to
200 mph and one's going to maybe 80 70
mph tops in this country you know the
different speed so to stand there and
pontificate with authority and and
actually when it's factually incorrect
it's in fu ating because I love hijack
journalistic standards and I think we're
compromising it with this tokenism and
if if the girls let me ask good enough
to get there it should be on a
meritocracy it shouldn't be on this
tokenism because they're filling a
quoted and we need to get um someone in
there because it that will lead even
further to to the sexism that we all
want to avoid we want it to be diverse
and inclusive but it has to be credible
we're talking about the best product we
output is in this country is Premier
League football the leite level
football okay but Joey let me ask you
got to protect you've never played to my
knowledge and correct me if I'm wrong
you've never played Champions League or
or World Cup football so does that
qualify you yeah to talk not
withstanding you're a very good
professional footballer does that
qualify you by your yard stick to
comment on Champions League football or
World Cup
football P everybody's entitled to
comment every you know I can talk about
Prem League football I can talk about
Taekwondo but it's about credibility and
journalistic standards rather than this
as I said this tokenism should be there
on Merit not for quots and if and
there's loads of you know women managers
you know Emma is fantastic s Serena vman
we've spoken about if they come across
and managing the men's game I have no
problem with that if they're the best
the best candidate similar with you know
there is some female pits out there who
are capable and and and Avance
credibility over a long period but also
there's lots at this moment there
there's well I don't want to name names
I'm not here to name names there's lots
of good people um but also the majority
are poor and the standards are poor and
it's factually incorrect information
well I he the comments from the
Liverpool uh Fulham game about you know
the Endo goal the the Japanese boy Endo
scores and the commentator was female
coom's female and she talks about Endo
scores with his laces now anyone who
watched that who had any knowledge of
football seen that Endo scored with the
side of his foot but no one because it
was female ccoms and and and female
commentator no one said I'm got a minute
that didn't happen so if you're a young
impressionable person who doesn't know
and you're coming for high journalistic
standards and content to educate and
inform which is what we're meant to do
if we're in those spots then then we
have to correct those mistakes and if
and if it goes unchecked it it it it
pulls the standard down and and we can't
allow that to happen for this woke
agenda
everything did you think that Hansen was
a good
commentator he's he was
fantastic right so when he said they'll
never win with kids about Manchester
United and they won it with kids he made
a terrible mistake I mean does that
discredit
him who who hasn't made a mistake we all
make mistakes but over a prolonged
period you have to have more successes
than failures so to get the opportunity
and this what we have to be careful of
all those great commentators you
mentioned before mty got dress a soul
brilliant of what he did their
opportunities are going to be restricted
because female ex female players are
getting those opportunities so we got to
be careful here because you know I want
a healthy game where women can go to the
football and enjoy it which they are
I've never seen more women PS out
football matches than what I currently
see or women's opportunities within
football and that's fantastic and long
may that continue we need to be
incredibly inclusive right across the
board but it has to be for people who
were good enough who who've AED the
right to be there I don't care where
you're from how many games you've played
but you have to have a body of work
that's credible to get you there not
just you get an opportunity because you
fill a quoter or you take a box and
we've got we've got a set C for what it
is and the world's gone
crazy all right let's take a short break
when we come back I've got three women
lined up who will be responding to you
Joey but you've agreed to stay and
listen to what they have to say and I'll
get your response to that as well
that'll be awesome I've got to get off
I've got to get off
[Music]
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well you know what
I love about tour today we do it all
sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scr you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy there
needs to be one human per machine to
come and rectify beachs and the clanks
and when it goes R unexpected item in
bagging area I know are we only going to
be trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from Gram was president of the Cambridge
Union which is the rubbish version of
being president of the Oxford
unit Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking living if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's about Twitter
you sons of can you please reinstate my
account yeah thank you this is a major
Summit President Biden decided this was
important after watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a
rational talk TV it's the only place
where you get the
truth this is talk
[Music]
TV well welcome back to P uncensored uh
Joey Barton's given defense of his views
about female pundits in football so are
female pundits qualified to talk about
the men's game well I've got some women
here who would like to respond uh and
they are uh Bianca Westwood who was the
first ever female football reporter for
soccer Saturday Paul Davis is a
youtubing anti-feminist and Kate B is a
co-founder and presenter of the offside
Rule and football 365 all right let me
start with you Bianca I'd imagine that
you were going slightly nuts as you
heard that but maybe I I don't want to
speak for you what is your
response
yeah absolutely I mean usually I
wouldn't give those kinds of opinions
any particular Credence but the way in
which he tweeted especially calling out
the young girl the vlogger from
Manchester City I just thought it was
out of order because I've been on the
the wrong end of dogs abuse when I very
first started reporting and it it it it
didn't sit well with me this is a young
girl she's on social media she's not
presenting news night she's not saying
she's an expert in football she's there
because viewers of football are changing
we're getting more streamers we're
getting more influences and and that's
that's a different argument entirely so
that's particularly the reason why I
didn't like what he said but who is
qualified to speak on football then
because I've been watching the game for
over 40 years my first game at West Ham
was before Joey Barton was even born um
I've been watching the game the whole
time I've watched hours and hours and
hours of football I work behind the
scenes at Sky for 10 years before I was
even given a shot on camera watching
many of my male colleagues who were
probably not always as good as I was
getting chances that I was never given
so I don't really understand exactly
what you need to know how long do we
need to work in the game behind the
scenes before we're allowed on on camera
to be a pundit you know the laws are the
same I can read a game of football Emma
Hayes Serena vman can both read games of
football you saying that they can't
provide Insight it sounds to me like
Joey's got a problem with particular
female pundits who to his knowledge
haven't done enough in the game but how
does he know and and how do do we
quantify and qualify that because there
are efl players who are commenting cooms
being pundits on Champions League games
what level do you have to get to before
you're allowed as far as Joey Barton is
concerned to be able to be a pundit on
the men's game well that's a that's a
yeah that's a good question let me bring
in Kate Kate what is your response to
Joey B I think it's really clear that
Joey doesn't appreciate that women can
study journalism too and they can study
Sports journalism and if you're Bianca
Westwood you can watch thousands of
hours of football and commentate and
Report into a Sky Sports Studio as she
did for decades on the men's game and be
very informed there has to be something
more to this I think look let's take
Alex Scott okay she's got a degree in
sports writing and broadcasting she's
played for England 140 times she played
for her Club career over two decades how
is she not qualified to talk about the
game just like any other pundit whether
you're talking about Mark Chapman Jake
Humphries none of them have played the
game but they've done the same as the
rest of us they've studied journalism
they love the game and they're
expressing their learned opinion and
assessment on the game I don't
understand why that's so
tricky well Pearl I can see you rolling
your eyes there you clearly don't
agree well I keep seeing women given
special handouts and special treatment
I'm seeing the same thing that he's
seeing you know um one thing you didn't
put in in my bio is I'm actually a
semi-pro athlete I've been involved in
athletics for 20 years um and no men and
women's sports are not the same men jump
higher they run faster so I I see where
he's coming from when I was listening to
him talk he was talking about the best
person for the job should be the one
that gets it I I didn't see anything
wrong with what he said but some of the
women who are getting these jobs are the
best women I mean I looked at I've
looked at their Instagrams they look
like influencers I mean I mean come on I
don't understand why you is an
influencer i the one the one girl you
guys brought up earlier I I didn't know
her but I've seen women's soccer um or
sorry football here I'm in the UK um but
women's football they they make it into
an agenda and it becomes a political
agenda and I hate it it ruins the
sanctity of women's sports then it just
becomes all about this woke nonsense I I
agree with him I think it needs to be
the best person for the job I think it
is the best person for the job I don't
know what kind of problem Joey's got is
this a woman's
problem s effectively Joe is saying Joe
is saying that his eight nyear old
daughter never grow up to be a football
commentator yes why do you guys put
words well how is she different how is
she different if she goes to study
journalism let me bring Jo about the
game let me bring Joey back to respond
just like Kelly Kates how's that
different all right let's Joe's been
listening to all this
Jo well
said I take on board every you know I've
known I've known Bianca being in around
the game for as long as she has and
she's worked incredibly hard and does a
fantastic job she I wouldn't say
Bianca's there on tokenism that's not
what you know she's worked incredibly
hard and has AED that recognition and
reward within the industry but that's
not everybody that's in the game on the
female commentary side that's not and as
the as the lady rightly points out there
she's seeing exactly what I've said this
is not sexism this is saying the best
person for the opportunity should get
that role we've seen when when an inch
has been given in other sports you know
I think you know maybe in your
Collegiate sing we've seen huge problems
with um L Thomas and Riley Gaines and I
don't want to even go into that but
we've got to be careful that we we
promote the best person for for the job
who's worked the hardest to get there
and for for me in the in the the sport
that I believe I'm a Bonafide expert at
the women haven't reached the level in
the commentating and punditry as the men
you know and and and they getting
opportunities that we strict the men's
opportunities and that's wrong we
shouldn't create we should create a icy
the best who work the hardest with the
most ability get get on and get and get
rewarded and get recognition me say
something come to I'll come wait a
minute wait a minute time out everybody
I want to just readback Joey's own words
with that first tweet it wasn't a
question of meritocracy you said women
shouldn't be talking with any kind of
authority in the men's game come on
let's be serious it's a completely
different game Bianca there was no there
was no meritocracy it was all
women okay no no no listen Bianca do you
think the Bianca can I just ask you a
question and I respect your opinion
massively I respect your opinion
massively do you think the women's game
and the men's game is the same
game the laws of the game are exactly
the same the same rules apply you know
whether it's yellow card red card
offside you can read the game it's still
exactly the same there's two goals and
11 players play and you can bring on
been tackled at full speed about that
have you ever been tackled at full speed
by a fully grown man and the
veloces CH op to do with it you seem to
have changed your opinion Joey when you
were earlier you had a problem with
women who to talk about the
game to talk about the game and now
you're saying the game's different youif
he's changing his mind he's changing his
mind
have you got a problem with the
journalistic coverage or have you got a
problem with the playing of the game
please don't all talk over each other
you just shouting at me I can't hear us
being a top player doesn't mean you're
going serious conversation this is
becoming a fast but not all P the men's
game I'm here to talk about giving these
women a chance joery you're
not to get shouted by you to have a
sensible
conversation not everybody is a
consumate broadcaster when they very
first start did you ever see Gary
Neville when he was first on Monday
Night Football he said himself he wasn't
brilliant you have to learn on the job
when you're live you can't learn live
television anywhere but live television
that doesn't mean they don't know
anything about the game maybe they're
just not brilliant at broadcasting yet
when I is that women keep getting
absolutely Terror she's not than anyone
else you not done you've not done this
either I got absolutely terrorized when
I first started live reporting because
people said I knew nothing about
football that wasn't the case I've been
watching football since I was 6 years
old I wasn't a great broadcaster at all
maybe these female pundits have to be
given a chance now I get men coming up
to me she been talking for Great I Am
I'd like to know I'd like to know from
Joey B which which women are not
qualified to do this because I see some
very talented you got give us one name
of someone you really good job and I'd
like to know which ones do not deserve
one name Joey before Man City so he
should tell us are you guys let me ask
Joey Joey one name Joey or someone you
don't think is up to
it one name Bianca would you like one
name one name one name I'm not even I'm
not I'm not even going there I'm I don't
have to give you anything I've come on
to a sensible debate and you just want
to shout the problem is Joey when you
talk about all right I'm got to leave it
there when you talk about this I'm going
to leave it there all I would say listen
Everyone's entitled their opinion all I
listen we got leave it there all I would
say is I I do think Joey I do think
Joey's being a bit unfair if you talk
about all women in your Tweet and then
you won't name a single woman you
actually personally object to but think
it should be a meritocracy that is a
confusing message look I will say also
as I end this I will say this I will say
We've Ended the debate I will say this
there are a lot of men who I saw
replying to Joey and they've replied to
us who agree with him so this is a
debate that probably ought to be aired
and we've had it and I appreciate you
all joining me so thank you very much
entitled well un sensor next a small
tribute to a giant of British poetry and
acting and activism so after the
[Music]
break we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well
crial to using XL Bully dogs as weapons
to threaten others no matter how well
Tred most dog owners will tell you a dog
can turn do you know what I love about
to today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are prob Palestine that is
just that's not right you swear an Al in
the police to act without fear or favor
the co inquiry seems to have turned into
a sort of pantomim there's not really
any substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million pound so far so40 million so far
results nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trying sources like meta and
Google where is our unbiased news going
to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin B
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for a liit if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegans
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walked into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man MC he should be easy enough to catch
this guy shouldn't he I mean he's got
house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
being a party political broadcast on
behalf of the reform UK
party
kids think all they have to do is take
pictures of everything just shut down
Tik Tok problem solved this is really
unfair what what what's unfair if it's
on camera we're not doing interviews yes
I'm going to do you're going to Res yes
cuz I cannot continue my work when I say
I am God I'm not joking did you feel
Elvis was controlling I've been
answering your question you answer mine
it's actually not my job to answer your
questions are you prepared to call h a
terror group is it possible to have a
rational asked you two questions should
a mass stay in power and are they a
terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV is the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
[Music]
that
welcome back to unsensored some very sad
news to the writer poet activist and
author Benjamin Zephaniah who was
remembered as a Titan of British
literature has died age 65 he died on
Thursday with his wife by his side after
being diagnosed with a brain schor just
eight weeks ago a statement on his
Instagram said we shared him with the
world and we know many will be shocked
and saddened by this news and tributes
PED in for the proud brammy uh zephan
was born and raised in hansworth
Birmingham a son of a Barbadian uh
postmaster and Jamaican nurse he was
dyslexic and left school aged 13 unable
to read and write and yet he wrote this
extraordinary poem called the British
poem take some pics Kelts and sers and
let them settle and overrun them with
Roman conquerors remove the Romans after
approximately 400 years add lots of
Norman French to some angles Saxons
Judes and Vikings then stir vigorously
mix some hot Chileans cool Jamaicans
Dominicans trinidadians and agans with
some Ethiopians chinese vietnamese and
Sudanese then take a blend of Somalians
Sri Lankans Nigerians and pakistanis
combine with some ganes and turn up the
heat sprinkle some fresh Indians
Malaysians bosnians Iraqis and
bangladeshis together with some Afghans
Spanish Turkish Kurdish Japanese and
Palestinians that add to The Melting Pot
leave the ingredients to simmer and some
Unity understanding and respect for the
future serve with Justice and
enjy that was Benjamin Zephaniah a great
poet I didn't agree with all his
political views he was a staunch
Carbonite he was a vegan but my God I
love the passion and the eloquence that
he brought to the stuff that he said and
we will miss him he was a great force in
this country and uh clear evidence of
the British poem that he so beautifully
wrote Benjamin Zephaniah thank you
that's all from us tonight whatever
you're up to keep it unsensed good
night
[Music]
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costume criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn do you know what I love
about talk today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David camon I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
done through normalizing relations with
Saudi Arabia the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming round the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and Rich he soon at the
other reshuffles usually very dull this
one had booster Rockets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what Rashi sinak has done the
question now is what he does next the
police are pro Palestine that is just
not right you swearing o in the police
to act without fear or favor the co
inquiry seems to have turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy talk TV
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners do you have a message
for Sadi Khan we're not stopping until
you
stop the amount of time it's taken the
number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million pound so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold
that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on Talk t sitting on his fat ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan you have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegans
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC Mouse
man MC man he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got house for the
Bice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film do